hello everybody and welcome back to
drunk minecraft with me Bob and Wade hi
everybody hi to cut don't say hi okay
good to commemorate the end of our town
here we're gonna blow up mega bad kids
watermelon patch pretty sure the server
just okay let's just hope that it didn't
set off like yeah cuz you guys are gonna
be timed out you come back everything's
gonna be gone oh god oh god I thought
you had a backup zombie Oh
[Laughter]
epic intro perfect and let the quality
be but you guys drinking today I am
drinking captain Morgan's and dr. pepper
it's delicious I have Bacardi Rum
Hawaiian pine still next second gen it's
still there get all the way message
eautiful it's still there get out of the
way message I am living the high life
okay it still exists I'm not dead
yeah okay no
I survived it's it's gone it's it done I
don't know I think so
we're hey I gotta get back - here we go
I got blown up into the ground with
nothing take that mega-bad kill oh oh
okay
oh there's some water hey there's one
piece of TNT here I'm blown up Oh lag oh
boy what happened oh where am i I'm
scared it's done
hey wait I see someone hey papa
how's it going I can't see anything I
can't get out of the underground somehow
oh they're all we're underground yeah
like yeah I walk so if I have torches I
should get them out the sniper is like
nagging for some reason okay here we go
all right we're dying I'm dying
stop hitting me who's hitting you going
on oh my god zombie what's happening
mark I think we broke it it's like the
blocks are trying to regenerate for some
reason so you guys are getting in tomb
in the mess that was the pre explosion
blocks let's just run away okay I can't
see another way I'm trying to mine I'm
trying to mine oh that was intense
okie dokie better baby are we safe I
don't know but there's more on the epic
tale of Justice yeah I mean a waterfall
the game even lets us leave this but
there's more punishment that must be
doled out oh no as you people may have
noticed my statue is missing its crown
of gold I wonder where it went
when when did the title of this change
from drunk minecraft to creepy minecraft
okay
Bob wasn't here for the executive
decision yeah I didn't know we are
supposed to be creepy through some
deductive reasoning we discovered that
the thief of the crown is none other
than death still living here please boos
don't grief where are you Bob I'm inside
the book thing I'm by the statue where
are you oh please poor Bob - I'm here
okay oh I found some TNT all right this
is justice ready ready doing it justice
oh yeah and that the person who lived in
the house next to him also stole some
stuff so he got wait I think that's the
Coliseum no that's the prison the
Coliseum got blown to hell well great
loop into prison
you blew in that's yeah do not pass go
there's no such thing as $200 what what
it's he's monopoly dick what all right
it
that's enough justice time to move on
some other stuff up now you know as
pretty Sh
no no we got to move on to real real
real stuff like what adventure maps' Oh
Bob you don't have the server that's
right hang on guys I got a what I don't
have been in enchantment wouldn't Oh
what is this [ __ ] I don't know but
someone please give Bob the IP even to
the other server what that I fell I'm on
top of the world where are you
why I was not under the world wait what
are you drinking again uh Bacardi Rum
Jose Cuervo tequila a little bit of
vodka Hawaiian Punch and something else
oh that's pretty good
Bob were you drinking I forgot living
the high life I so sad for you ha ha
that's sad I love it I said that's it
there's so much random crap I picked up
from open this wrap up the explosions
Bob do you have VIP I'm adding it right
now okay all right we leave we're
transfer we go into that server
transferring yes first [ __ ] I'm gonna
have to blur the IPS idiot I'll blur it
out in post I'll fix it in post unless I
don't Roo alive unless I don't remember
at all and then oh yes I'm taking all
this sugar our starter chess what is
this thing called dungeon run chest up
wins like temple run or some attempt at
lost temple that's some like that hey
put on your gear I'm all geared up this
is temple run so why don't we start with
leather stuff in our inventory if we're
just gonna get Diamond that was obvious
mark why is that a thing yeah tell me to
[ __ ] myself
I don't want me to [ __ ] myself us
[ __ ] you way but I wonder why I
didn't notice
I feel so burned okay rules read and
follow all of them good luck three I
think there's some rules missing just
collect all the rules just collect all
the diamonds and iron here's something
those aren't luck out there rules gold
ingot worth three points diamond worth
two points
iron worth one point if you get zero to
30 you're mad
31 to 50 you're good 51 to 394 good job
95 perfect 95 plus you got more points
than what was possible somehow I feel
like I'm gonna get more than 95 points
just saying good sooner we got the
server admin here with us what the Bob I
don't know how did that happen
I didn't do any out dick why mine fire
don't know don't die before we even
start okay okay well shut up right now
because we destroyed my Tatari recording
of your drunken are drunken are very low
so the drunkle over there gun it's like
you think I knocked off work today it
started drinking at 5:00 a.m. so that's
pretty early sounds like something I did
right you started way too early
alright whatever let's go come on excuse
I'm gonna need a boat shut up loose ends
okay I have a boat if you guys see a
boat I have a boat let's do this Bob's
going up lippy flop you're doing it
let's do this there's a total we kill
things are doing my opera there's no
explanation mark there's a temple here
get that code down go talk out in there
oh there's water I get it I'm get off of
me mark
yeah that's me oh hey switch here hey
there's a switch here cut chunk
I didn't appear to do anything I hit all
the switches at the same time or
something I don't know I found one I
don't have torches if I can't place
anything we can't place anything I can't
place anything either
sound oh [ __ ] later I found a diamond
[ __ ] and diamond I've got three
irons at worth points yeah points
the gold is three diamonds are two irons
one I'm winning I adventure mode all
placing and breaking are disabled ah
oh [ __ ] ow jumped off of us oh here here
here here here
come here come here it's down here
oh I don't know where that is where are
you guys Hobbs lost forever
Wow Bob we hardly knew you you guys you
go up you got to find a place to drop
off like your mom what yeah you heard me
Oh Gold I found gold not gettable gold
but gold is this my throne
looks like my throne huh I heard
something kachunk something went kachunk
yes I found a chest there something went
a trunk in the night something happened
yes there was a chest where and I opened
it right here where I'm bright on it why
don't I get anything cuz you suck and
you're a dick what and you suck this is
my all I found it what oh there I put it
back what did I even do I don't know
what I did doors on the side oh okay now
I'm in gold and iron get back here lady
you're such a dick my chest there's
nothing in them no oh my god
wait what I'm not waiting this is a
competition this is not a competition
I'm gonna win the competition
it's a gown [ __ ] yeah I'm gonna win
sprint I thought it wasn't a competition
where it is now so shut up well I found
a big empty room how about that mapless
switch here oh did you die Oh
lava hurts interesting sidenote
lava hurts mark finally found a chest no
I found a switch I found that chest the
next level yes I survived it
I bit you all wish I guess who's winning
no Bob is winning because I hit the
switch
I'm still at fire just don't care do you
you guys don't care about me no okay
anyway damn it wait this is not a
competition okay I hit it
what did I already hit it it didn't do
anything okay it probably did something
but your to do we use votes on the law
okay there might be something in the
lava hang on let me check
are you dead yet no I
I'm mysteriously being healed seriously
okay uh some of these puzzles are
supposed to be tough right um okay no
I'm going back there's something out
there something else where maybe I don't
know hey no wait no this is exactly the
same and we're really bad at this okay I
mean did we get this chest here yeah
okay Bob I think then I'm the greatest
well I mean like I'm in this room I
don't remember there being gold here and
Bob you and I have to do all the work
Mark's just dying okay okay
anyway so um wait with this way
didn't we didn't oh yeah yeah okay I'm
still higher why am I on fire this is
shenanigans no are you guys that you
guys go back up yeah we're going my way
go up and then go farther up cuz there's
something here hang on I go farther up
yeah no that would make sense
you don't ever make sense I just wanted
to make fun of you hello everyone's
gonna laugh at that joke they're gonna
be all farther up bounce right what a
titty man what a titty apparently
apparently that's my insult I'm going
with that's your catchphrase mark you're
such a titty math no [ __ ] pads mark this
is adventure mode not boring go or
you're supposed to just Oh iron yeah I
got iron I finally got some iron it's
the worst what am i dying your [ __ ]
mouth temple is on fire [ __ ] are you
guys even close to where I am
no I did it wrong yeah I know you did I
was dealing oh I don't have any food
that's ones I know you should have a
bunch of I'm like I didn't I haven't
eaten one man [ __ ] you know you should
eat some food but thank thank you Father
I just I was unclear on that familiar
where you are with this game why can't I
open this chair I got locked it mark
stop yelling guys psychopath guys what
guys come here we're working on it here
we go
in here yeah how you got a fire - okay
Bob Bob Bob Bob I'm Bob following the
path of the fire one Bob yeah yeah I see
it
okay here we go
[Music]
is there a way to enter this and not
catch on fire oh I did it
good job for you holy [ __ ] yep
okay now did you guys see that no oh
holy crap I can't see anything
a B and E's all switches 22 switches Oh
God I'm looking in the back area I've
joined them all I'm finding secrets
floors first sign first one sign second
two suns third three signs for three
signs with three signs sixth for signs
seventh six signs you are here sign DB
11 down oh these are hints b11 down Oh
Bob just turned them all down
oh sorry Lee 11 down it's down down
everything else is down - I can hardly
see anything in here I can't turn off
like did Han brightness max I still
[ __ ] dark in there yeah there are
signs posted oh I got another sign found
okay alright b10 up be put in up
emergency lever here put emergency oh
that's for if we get stuck be 10 is up
be 11 is down I are you taking damage -
mark yeah okay floors 1 we are on the no
bonus chest on the temple what I don't
know I'm just looking for more signs
this is hard
how do I know where I've been this is
pretty challenging first red crow drunk
people
efore down b4 down for what see what I
did there
I'm drinking you guys look for sign or
mark how do I tell where you've been and
I just look around if you if the signs
already been done then you know it's
been done how how are you reading signs
in this by the way I can't see any I
turned up the brightness
oh so you're cheating it's not cheating
I'll turn my brightness all the way up
it's cottage just thing your brightness
counts is cheating I was odd
well my brightness was turned all the
way down so that would probably explain
why I couldn't see anything yeah yeah
see how you're a dick well at least I'm
not a cheater
oh wait no I already got that one b11
down I already got that yep I'm having
trouble finding new ones I found I found
one I found one which one c9 up okay
done so I've been I've been that way Bob
wait what there's no no see a five down
hey Mark hey have you been down this
hallway yeah I have but look again I'm
gonna miss them there's no c9 yeah each
day five is down down Rafe I thought you
talk you just said a part that a five
down yeah that's right
I found one [ __ ] you Bob a five up Park
about listening to Bob I believed him I
believed him on that one
oh we're [ __ ] now we're never gonna
figure any of this out no cuz I don't
trust either one of you okay um is this
kind of like stump the wade it's
actually what this has turned into no
longer the way it stumps all of us
all right through my sword why okay now
what you want to do Wade I'm gonna I'm
gonna follow you mark that way we can
work those two very likable levels are
we supposed to go up the levels and
check those two how do you go up I
haven't seen any stairs or anything oh
it's gonna take forever oh wait what
pulling the levers turns torches on what
this hallway was dark now there are
torches what
come come see where I don't know where
you are I'm to the right of the levers
board
what Oh No maybe I'm like maybe I just
turned my brightness up emergency no why
do you have beaten up right yeah b10 is
up okay thank you guys been back here
I've apparently there's like one hallway
and I keep finding it I just had to
climb over something to get to another
place
oh no wait this is it oh this secrets on
the seventh floor there are six signs we
got one two oh four yeah we're dumb
we're dumb I think we only got four of
them though no we must have gotten more
and on each floor there so [ __ ] that
Dobby
emergency there are you guys there are
four signs on the sixth floor three on
the fifth three on the fourth three on
the third two on the second and one on
the first floor you really want to go
through all that not particularly
emergency well I think I'm drunk enough
I just spilled beer all over me good
party foul we're like 10 minutes into
the video be 10 up be 10 up ah no here
we go mysteriously whoa we seem to have
won Hey we win oh oh oh I'm not leading
the way mine wait this is a potion of
fire resistance I know what I need to do
oh [ __ ] bail watch this watch this
Oh hahaha don't hurt oh not even a
little bit how you guys Oh No
why am I getting knocked into the lava
and someone's a dig this doesn't hurt at
all with you Baba
you okay there you don't look so good no
I'm dying a lot seems to be lovely
Oh the lamas know so freaky right now ah
I got it what's wrong with you guys I've
get the next chest you guys suck I got
this one I'm still dying like total up
our points at the end no it's a
competition what is that how does that
not register with you okay maybe because
you're an [ __ ]
yeah it's competition side the floor on
my jump through that jump through it no
jump through the lava no head serious
jump through the lava hey you guys are
dicks no I'm dead serious
wait come down here we're jump through
the lava there is [ __ ] down here look at
this how does that work I guess
they're made maps yes someone literally
like they made this map and they placed
everything themselves and then they
found the switch already Bob no flip it
I bid I just flip the one over here
where I am there's no switch where I am
it's in the corner on the wall
Oh I said there's a switch I got it okay
I got it
got this so that we all three just do a
switch maybe yeah
but there four corners still windows
look I think this just opened really
okay oh yeah my way this is cool ooh I
think we need a minecart for the next
part we dick I wasn't me actually I did
not hit you
how do I mind cars I'm really bad I'm
gonna like place it and then right-click
the fricken and get in and then I fish
you jump dick you jumped out here we go
I'll get me a knife summary get that
fifty carton all there hey guys when you
go on this track there's a chest you're
gonna pass make sure you click it's on
the left
I missed it it's on the left it's on the
left oh [ __ ] I got you get it now I'm
getting out hello I'm getting out of the
cart I'm getting it that two diamonds
there was one on the right oh yeah I'm a
walk see you never mark I'm coming I'm
a-coming oh I'm running I'm running no
I'm going the other way I'm running
son of a [ __ ] I'm running I turned
around running yeah where's this other
chest that you missed I think it was on
I don't know for sure that I saw the
second when I could have been just a
tree block I said I get out Bob what is
wrong with you get out I get out yeah I
got this I found an enchanting table oh
no I think my screen did that thing
where it went really black again I think
your grace is the best Oh son of a [ __ ]
you got kicked seriously how do I get
out I don't know right-click the
minecart I'm stuck in my mind Carter
there's a gold ore here oh never mind
okay
anyway what are we doing looking for a
lever to place on a diamond block
I'm not doing that we can't place
anything though there's an exception do
something in the forest here there's
something in here sweetie I found two
diamond yay oh no that's a sheep that's
not something you guys go on a fan of
Sheba um are you gonna make sweet love
to your chief found the lever battle
ever I thought some water
good for you I thought you were stuck
Bob no I got out okay oh crap I might be
stuck in the water I'm really good at
minecraft let's in the end of all there
we go I'm inside inside what's this town
thingy oh hey I got ported I'm so good
at this game I don't even have to try
I'm gonna pour myself more drink why is
there a melon pumpkin patch huh what I
found a melon pumpkin patch okay sheep
don't care what what what would do with
this lever what what I said what do I do
with this lever I did answer you yeah I
heard him say that too so I didn't hear
thing audience did you hear anything yes
please answer us right now and clear
this up we heard it you're not watching
this sure that's that's two in favor of
me oh man I just oh yeah we both heard
it are you guys in the town
oh I found it I found it I'll keep
finding empty chests this is really
frustrating
well the ender chests are always empty I
think that's okay I found the letter I
found it's just it's probably empty Oh
Gold awesome son of a [ __ ] found gold
hey I found the diamond block in ass
obviously no one cares but yeah just
took my lover Oh moving ahead huh what
what I'm moving home we haven't found
all the chess job then moving a heads
this way huh whenever you're done oh I
found that melon patch what about
sucking ten [ __ ] in a row well I said
bark likes to suck penis and it's this
way what huh
oh I remember writing in that sign
where do we go ah melons must blow it up
market where do we go must blow this I
told you guys okay you said come this
way I must this corner this corner must
blow it what corner must blow it up I'm
running away from the melon patch oh I
think I see you must see how nonspecific
your directions were I don't know where
we're at how much but I just break the
level I don't care all right fine
wait [ __ ] this guy let's go yep moving
on right where are you guys see ya
foreigner where the corner it was so
obvious
this is the corner who's more stone
pickaxes mole go to the corner which
corner just going one by the melon patch
now we stop by the melon patch where is
it it's the corner mark I saw you guys
going this way so I'm going this way
that's our did you find the lever
there's a doorway to your right or left
I got it shut up I got it I'm not stupid
oh I'll be a liver in here somewhere
Hey look your chest Oh be careful
do you see a lever be careful oh if we
go underwater here oh wait I have an
idea I think we're supposed to use the
waterfall to climb up on top oh I'll use
the water to go underneath yeah we went
backwards when you go underneath though
no the other way what huh
what there's nothing up here there's
literally nothing up here why did I get
a stone pickaxe if I can't use it why
are you complaining about everything you
get maybe you can use it have you tried
breaking these blocks yeah fire wait why
were you on fire wait
on fire
okay um ah sorry uh uh okay all right um
you know what solved this puzzle and
your mom dynamite to that but there's no
such thing as dynamite
there's TNT yes that's dynamite TNT it's
TNT
it's dynamite dynomite oh no don't worry
sing sing Bob no sing sings wait yeah no
I don't want to okay um there's some
sort of secret that we're missing maybe
we have to explore the canals maybe you
should explore your mom oh I'm just
gonna explore the canals
oh I'm floating on top of this water I
went that there there's nothing if my
mom was a part of Minecraft
my mind is gonna be blown ooh
that's not the only thing that's gonna
be blown yeah that's what I was thinking
yeah I set that one up real nice for you
thank you yeah softballs yeah and so
does she
oh wait oh that's not right
I like that I can eat watermelon
underwater why wouldn't you be able to I
don't know I don't ever eat watermelon
underwater in real life so something
that you could do though mm-hmm I don't
know I feel like you would drown if you
tried to eat underwater use Niebuhr yeah
hobby emergency are there like hints
like a pro tip or something just the tip
I don't know I haven't I haven't gone
this far when I was playtesting oh my
god this far who made this some person
on planet minecraft yeah this isn't made
by zombie I thought he made all the
minecraft maps yeah everything is the
creator of Minecraft yeah surprise
zombie is not and Jeb there's
person that's kind of the impression
that I had gotten okay apparently also
the brains behind Steve Jobs wait whoa
wait there's a cobblestone there what's
with that okay might be hope that what
would that accomplish break it I don't
think I can break it no no okay
I figured it out we're all idiots really
hey come look at the waterfall what
about it
I will show you oh you're gonna be such
an idiot and you're an [ __ ]
bye wait what I found the exit you're a
liar
yeah I found the exit dirty dirty liar
did you try pick axing this stuff I did
I can try again nothing up here
yeah just an [ __ ]
sergeant ass okay anyway we're gonna I'm
gonna solve this watch I got the special
tool to fix this situation
it's called knob a play some charity
right here stop it
play TT right here don't blow it up just
one there we go
help it up with what flint and steel
zombies Flint yeah yes dan real closer
Bob I was going to winner winning
winning I'm pretty sure that is Charlie
Sheen would have beaten that post
winning okay drugs and sex off outta
Chester oh I got bedrock close the pike
kill you guys close Linton steel I got
it oh no wait who got it who got that
huh
who got it Oh anything problem I have to
close mush
I have to close the passaggio
wait you're such a donk this is a
massage doc eponymous that's not your
catchphrase
danke Potamus catchphrase now yep I
thought it was your sentence it's so I
forgot you're such a tits yeah okay I'm
gonna find the right way you are gonna
find the wrong way this amazing Simon
Blanc
I keep finding diamonds is that good
shut your face
I got bedrock can I turn my armor into
diamonds and win no or maybe I don't
know that's already a dead end don't
worry isn't our armor already made of
diamond I gotta close the pathology I
was getting on that Wade I was on it on
it I have to close the precise with
bedrock close the sighs passage massage
aye aye aye
I'll allow it I'm gonna loss forward
Thank You bub
thank you Bob cannot allow your
existence mark Thank You Tucker HS I am
yeah oh [ __ ] didn't even check that
chest I just found a bunch of diamonds
and stuff really I think you're a liar I
think you're a dirty dirty liar I also
just found a diamond brick I think I'm
going the right way
where we see your nametag by the place
where I am I don't know where it is some
days are key that's the point
may I see you I see us you not for long
oh [ __ ] I've been here before I'm doing
it wrong alright we're splitting up
we're splitting up Hey I just had a
really hilarious idea and remembered why
we're all morons
you can climb on top of the maze oh
[Laughter]
we're all so freakin stupid wait which
way do we go though toward the forest I
think the forces are all around us
I'm going towards the good for what does
this random diamond block because I
think this thing means anything robably
I found a big clearing hey Mark I found
the passage you found the pathar
now the passaggio not that either the
passage there's something here wait come
back I found something there's something
here
look I see is this app Asajj Bob where
are you
I found stuff f [ __ ] you Bob I found a
town [ __ ] is it bad that I'm down in the
massage I found all there's chests down
here is what I need to show my devotion
to the gods that's what I found iron
back here going into the passaggio just
mine gold on gold oh no I think I just
went back god damn it I'll be port Bob
to us cuz he's an idiot I jumped back
through the lava lake yeah you're such
an idiot okay it's getting foggy down
here where are you guys where you should
be has to go I almost said it or did you
go down we went down there are levelers
here there are lovers here levers levers
did you how do I go in Tommy where I
wanted to us cuz he's an idiot hey it
doesn't make any sense I'm bad at
puzzles it can't be helped he was born
this way yeah just like that Lady Gaga
song wait why the hell am i following
you you're just jumping around like an
idiot I'm very smart idiot no that's not
how that works
wait I hear some things jumping around
no I hear sugar sugars ha ah [ __ ]
there's lava what ha ha I got it I got
it I got it
hang on I got I don't got it wait ma'am
oh [ __ ] you there we go okay I got this
I'm climbing the waterfall I'm climbing
this stuff to this switch and Bango I'm
just not gonna do anything we're
supposed to do Oh who's the winner not
you oh I found a gold block oh where the
water goes oh yeah well I'm killing wade
Dimond hey why am I on fire please try
to kill Wade oh I'm the best there ever
was how'd you guys get there there was
water there was water I turned I turned
to switch somewhere I don't know what it
did probably got rid of the water that
we were using to climb up don't care
ask me how much I care well Hobbes
ducked down there and I'm stuck right
here
okay alright I got the chest up here but
I don't see anything else oh well you
know I'm just gonna disconnect I don't
see anything here
I don't see anything there's nothing
here flip the switch again well the
switches over there that's not helping
us alright also lose the switch flicked
see anything no where's the water at I
don't know I don't care
I found something but there's nothing
else here well I'm going back down can
we climb these vault urns
yes you can come to them now they have
to be against something okay is there
anything down like at the bottom that
changed I didn't change anything at the
bottom inai hit a switch up here but so
this is where we came in right these
chests yeah oh these vines were not here
before were they yeah they were maybe I
don't know okay um I found a thing to
climb up to a switch I can't get to it I
just hit that switch I hit that switch
Bob I'm up here I'm up there Bob that
don't want to go up there's nothing up
here there's nothing weights being
called it's just turning back okay Dog
the Bounty Hunter ah lost oh hey I'm up
here huh
we're up here good job you're up where I
am there's nothing here
Oh actually we're out of time we're out
of time so thank you everybody so much
for watching this has been drunk
minecraft with me Bob and Wade who went
away so thank you for watching and as
always see you in the next video bye bye
say bye I don't want to hey I figured it
out Bob